Key Technical Matters: How to Leave a Meeting.
No matter how contentious the meeting,...
...always shake hands with your counterparts while looking them in the eye...
...and saying something positive.
No hugs.
No high fives.
No butt slaps.
If you're hosting the meeting,...
...see your guests out as far as the door or elevator.
Talk about anything except what you just met about.
After a great meeting, don't say, "Great meeting!"
After a bad meeting, don't say, "Bad meeting!"
After a ho-hum meeting, don't say, "Ho-hum meeting."
In fact, never under any circumstances say "ho-hum" ever.
Do not say, "Hey, let's be careful out there,"...
...unless you just wrapped up a meeting with your fellow police officers.
Do not hand out gold stars to those who did a good job.
Even metaphorically.
The best attitude to have while leaving a meeting room is hopeful.
The second best attitude to have is kind of hopeful.
Do not tout the quality of your doodling...
...unless it's of remarkably high quality with fine lines and a certain panache.
Leave the last doughnut.
You can go back in a few minutes and grab it after everyone's walked away,...
...but for now, just walk away from the doughnut.